need some extra encouragement during
your next workout i know i do
rich demuro has a solution in today's
tech smart
[Music]
the new year usually means gyms are
newly packed but this year is a bit
different
and that means apps and at home workouts
will continue to be popular
here are some of the ways tech can get
you back on track
it's a new year and that means a fresh
start for fitness
anytime you're looking to reset fitness
is at the top of the the conversation
charlie hale is co-founder of shred an
app focused on the social aspects of
working out
when you look at social workouts as a
form of motivation
it's incredible and i think what we're
trying to do is just facilitate more and
more of that
link up with friends and family and get
a notification when they're working out
you can then actually view the workout
and choose to do that same workout as
well monitor each other's progress
compare stats and more shred is 13
a month don't have much space check out
treadley
their slim compact treadmill folds up
when you're not using it
this can fit anywhere you can roll it
out and take it to any place you want in
the house and
just open the handrail and start walking
treadly goes up to five miles an hour
virtually walk with a group of friends
or family or
use a new feature that lets you live
stream your workout
if you think about it the times that
you've walked the longest
is the time that you were walking with
one of your friends and you were talking
about anything
finally neo-u is like netflix but for
workout classes
browse by concept programs and
specialized instructors quality
and affordability make us really special
the videos work on nearly every platform
including phones and streaming devices
like roku
and fire tv neo is ten dollars a month
health and wellness is not just about
looking good it's more about feeling
good and it's that aura it's that vibe
that you have
when you're eating good and you're
you're exercising and you're healthy
it affects everything that you're gonna
do and i think that's really important
who needs a sweaty selfie when you've
live streamed your entire workout
am i right you can find links to
everything i mentioned on my website
just go to
rich on tech dot tv i'm rich camaro and
you
are tech smart